you had one job most people have heard
of kamikaze pilots young men who were
tasked with crashing their planes into
enemy warships these pilots could
ideally accurately target important
parts of ships and do more damage than a
traditional bombing run also it was
believed that the display of a kamikaze
pilot willingly sacrificing themselves
for Japan would demoralize the enemy now
the effects of kamikaze attacks are well
debated but something not spoken about
is what happened when they failed what
was to become of a kamikaze pilot that
Eva missed or wimped out so some
background as of 1944 things weren't
exactly going great for Japan and the
only hope of preventing America from
defeating them was to destroy or at
least [ __ ] their capital ships most
importantly their aircraft carriers
simply attacking the ships with
conventional means was too costly for
Japan as such taking young pilots
sticking them into planes loaded with
explosives and then ordering them to fly
into critical parts of enemy ships was
deemed to be a better strategy the men
chose him for this weren't just some
random champs but were some of the most
gifted pilots in Japan the training was
harsh but the rations were much better
and culturally kamikaze pilots were
revered pilots were expected to reflect
on death in their time off to prepare
them for their upcoming mission yet for
some this preparation and love that
Japan wasn't enough to get them to
introduce their face to the deck of an
American warship so what happened to
failed kamikaze pilots well many were
shot down before they even completed
their mission or could get there some
hit the wrong part of the ship or miss
completely and fell into the ocean we're
providing they survived they'd be
captured and taken to a prisoner of war
camp and before continuing there's a
common misconception that kamikaze
pilots were only given half a tank of
fuel to ensure they couldn't come back
which isn't true also there were
legitimate reasons for a pilot to turn
around and losing a world trained
kamikaze to a malfunction would be a
waste and the entire reason why Japan
turned to this strategy in the first
place was because their resources
including pilots were limited so pilots
that turned around because of technical
issues or bad weather would face no
consequences because it wasn't their
fault better luck next time and there
was going to be a next time those that
returned due to less easy to confirm
reasons like enemy resistance or the
inability to find their target would be
chastised and the number of these cases
was alleviated by undertaking kamikaze
attacks in groups and also getting the
pilots drunk so they wouldn't think too
much about the whole dying thing however
when only one survivor returned he
looked quite suspicious but remain
kamikaze pilots were valuable resources
and so Japan wanted to utilize every
single one of them thus no punishment
back out you go now there was a limit to
how often someone could return for
example there was one pilot that
returned nine times before he was
executed for cowardice for most pilots
though returning from a suicide mission
was to an extent expected in in many
cases not something that would get you
imprisoned or shocked like all resources
during the Second World War
Japan had to conserve who make the best
use of his kamikaze pilots if it were to
compete with the industrial might of the
United States had given that a single
kamikaze pilot could fit an aircraft
carrier out of commission for mumps they
were seen as something not to be wasted
hence while returning kamikaze pilots
weren't often punished I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching but thanks to my patreon
supporters whom you can see on screen
now and with an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette Ike Danny Maloney
Colin Castleman Marvin Castle Rob
Waterhouse Erin the white Jordan long
way Chris wicker Gustav Swann Gareth
Turner
Marcus Ozma Maggie packs Kowski David
Silverman spinning three plates
Spencer Lightfoot Lexi Schwinn Winston
Cawood Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett the original cage Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappell par shoe 19 and Mo